everything is getting more expensive
between inflation supply chain issues
and the labor shortage small business
owners are struggling so I'm here at the
Texas State Fair in Dallas to find out
how one of its newest vendors is
handling Rising costs
[Music]
okay we're going to finish the last two
orders from the classroom
so we have Carnitas Barbacoa carne asada
Chicken al pastor that's a melted cheese
Barbacoa onions cilantro and the
Barbacoa I want to start by by just
going through these receipts that you
brought tell me what we're looking at
here the first one that I want to show
you is the tortillas to have a taco
place you have to have tortillas yes
there will be no not many so I see that
you've got 64 dollars total for yellow
corn tortillas which is eight packages
you were not like ten dollars a box so
you're talking about ten percent of what
we used to pay before pandemic so how
much did that number used to be it used
to be 48 a case 48 an ounce
Jesus isn't alone in 2022 through
November food got over 10 percent more
expensive the flour costs up by over 24
and chicken up by 12 supply chain issues
avian flu droughts geopolitical issues
they all have an impact on the price of
food and that leaves restaurant owners
like Jesus making tough choices about
how to pass these costs on to customers
I tried to get the best product that I
can according to my prices when you pay
five dollars for a taco people expect
quality is it five dollars for one taco
I trust you even at 575 for Attack on
the octopus and people won't mind
because as far as the flavors the
texture and the quality so how have you
handle that increasing cost for you the
traditional attackers
or chicken they're 2.99 before the
pandemic if they were 225
the tortilla the cheese the meat and
everything went up even the produce you
have to increase it and people know
those things and they become more
generous they even tip more because they
know that the cost of living for all
their my family my employees I call them
family because we work 14 hours a day
together so they have to pay their bills
so people are very generous especially
here in Texas how did you determine what
your price ceiling was going to be so
what you do in order to produce money
and you don't overcharge you get their
food cost so how much you pay for a taco
and then you do it one and a half times
more for a lot of people they don't
increase the prices but on this ring is
Porsche but I wouldn't do that I won't
do that I prefer to increase my price a
little bit then give it a small portion
that's really interesting because right
now at the federal level the view is
that okay companies will start to
decrease their prices if we have
interest rates but it sounds like you're
saying that once you hit a certain price
point you're not gonna increase the cost
right I'm doing the same numbers that I
use to do but before I open for now
everything will cost a little more
Jesus learned the tricks of the trade at
home with his father I grew up on this
business since I was seven years old my
father used to have restaurants in
Mexico City so I tried to do more small
things but this is what I love the most
the food in my passion did you grow up
in Mexico City I grew up with two I was
17 then I came to Texas I live in New
York Vegas San Francisco for the past 30
years I lived here and your dad was in
the restaurant and there was some
business he was there he passed away
maybe you're like what
I'm pretty sure he would be very proud
to see what I copied all these tips are
for happiness it sounds like a real
family yes that's what I tried to us
family business and I told him if I can
do that you guys can do it it's not
about me it's about everyone very
grateful for me to see this when they
first start they come in now they have
better cars they have better houses and
I know you've had
we're so excited show you about that
very excited very tired yeah business is
great down there so the
first years they invite me this year
there's seven new vendors on the fair
and by far and the number one thanks
ladies are you able to tell if you've
made a profit from the work you're
putting in yes I already know that I
make very good profit from the number
that I was thinking we increased like 30
percent more I sell over 10 000
empanadas in the past 20 days tons of
tacos tons of margaritas Just a Dream
It's The American Dream
[Music]